if you think of an emergency there's a
good chance this comes to mind
however for the 12 million deaf people
in the uk there's no siren to say help
is on its way and making that 999 call
isn't easy
but today a new service launches for the
thousands of deaf people who use british
sign language or bsl ambulance please
my dad's had a stroke one click of a
button on the app connects users to a
bsl interpreter via video link
through them they can talk to a 999 call
handler in real time
until now deaf people have had to ask
others to call for help or use a
text-based system
this will be faster but that's not all
the biggest difference it's going to
make is to give deaf people
the independence
to make those kind of calls themselves
um
in a language which they are most
comfortable in and when you're
distressed
you need to be able to communicate in
your own language and not be trying to
think of how to communicate in a
different language
because english actually isn't the first
language for many deaf people british
sign languages so imagine trying to call
an ambulance in french when you don't
speak it and then trying to get all the
medical information you need across as
quickly and accurately as possible
that's the situation bryony found
herself in when her husband suffered a
severe allergic reaction out on a run i
wasn't able to ring 999
and i thought about texting my mum to
ask her to call 999 but then i thought
that's going to take too much time and
then relaying the call
so i was really panicking my husband
couldn't breathe and he was in and out
of consciousness
bryony had to drive her husband to the
nearest hospital to seek help
happily he survived
this service could save others the
stress brownie went through and saved
lives
madeleine ratchcliff sky news